Українські жінки можуть врятувати економіку країни
і принести державі додатковий дохід -
від 7 до 23 мільярдів доларів. Це станеться,
якщо чотири мільйони працездатних жінок,
які зараз не працюють із різних причин,
будуть залучені до роботи. Такі дані демонструє
актуальне дослідження Центру економічних стратегій.
Його автори переконують: саме в руках жінок
ключ до добробуту країни і навіть обіцяне урядом
зростання економіки України на 40%
за наступні 5 років може стати цілком імовірним,
якщо держава усуне причини, через які
мільйони українок не працюють.
- Перший сценарій - він такий найбільш оптимістичний.
Ми припускаємо, що всі жінки, які зараз
не працюють, почнуть працювати. Звісно, це
не зовсім реалістично, але це дозволяє побачити
максимальний потенціал. За нашими розрахунками,
такий максимальний потенціал становить 21% ВВП.
Це досить багато, бо якщо дивитися
на економічне зростання минулого й позаминулого року,
то це було близько 3%, тобто 21% - це як 7 років
такого економічного зростання.
Якщо перспектива залучити до праці всіх жінок
і додати до держбюджету 23 мільярди доларів
здається утопічною, то збагачення на 7 мільярдів
цілком можливе. Для цього достатньо зрівняти
кількість жінок і чоловіків, що працюють,
пояснюють експерти. Що ж саме стоїть на заваді?
- Однією з основних причин є діти, тобто відсутність
можливостей по догляду за дітьми. Тобто потрібно
стимулювати відкриття нових дитячих садочків:
як державних, так і приватних.
Серед жінок, які не працюють через догляд за дітьми
(а це половина опитаних) - наразі і Тетяна Сімак.
До декрету вона успішно будувала кар’єру в банківській сфері,
але тепер ця робота - не оптимальний варіант
для неї як молодої мами. Зарплатні до декрету
ледве вистачило б на оплату дитсадка.
- Потім ще важливий момент, якщо, наприклад,
дитина захворіє, я розумію, що
дуже багато роботодавців не будуть готові
раз на місяць на кілька днів чи на тиждень
чи навіть більше відпускати працюючу маму.
Саме тому Тетяна готова змінити сферу зайнятості,
але пропозицій на ринку праці, де враховувалися б
потреби матерів, практично немає.
А працювати повний робочий день вона не може
ще й через те, що в державних дитсадках
не знайшлося місця для її майже трирічного сина.
Причина - відсутність київської реєстрації.
- Ми вирішили віддати у приватний садочок,
поки що на півдня, бо це період адаптації і
є можливість трошки дешевше платити.
Нині в мене з’явиться в першу чергу час, щоб
зорієнтуватися у вакансіях, можливо,
десь перекваліфікуватися, можливо, щось засвоїти,
вивчити, бо з дитиною це нереально зробити…
Чи не єдина позитивна зміна останніх років -
урядова програма оплати послуг няні для дітей до 3 років.
Від початку 2019 року незалежно від зайнятості
і прибутків батьків кожна родина може щомісячно
отримати на це 1626 гривень. Знайти людину, яка б
погодилася доглядати за дитиною за ці гроші,
вкрай складно. Але, приміром, у садочку, до якого
пішов син Тетяни Сімак, можна лишити дитину,
і держава компенсує витрати.
- У нашому садочку діє така послуга і наш персонал,
я особисто, ми доглядаємо за дітками, коли мамі
треба у своїх справах відлучитися.
Дуже багато мам стали звертатися до нас, щоб
скористатися цією послугою, але, на жаль,
кількість місць обмежена.
Приватний садок - не єдине місце, де мами можуть
залишити дитину, щоб попрацювати.
Чотири роки тому в Києві з’явився перший коворкінг
для жінок із дітьми. Його заснували чотири мами,
які хотіли працювати, але не мали відповідних умов.
Тепер у "Зеленці" для дітей влаштовують
цікаві заняття, поки їхні мами працюють.
- До нас дійсно можна приходити працювати
з дітьми. Не потрібно шукати нянь: вони в нас є,
не потрібно шукати садочки і сепарувати дитину від мами.
Дитина знаходиться поруч.
Будь-якого віку.
Це може бути як місяць дитині, так і 3,4 чи 5 років.
Це для них є унікальна можливість прийти
і попрацювати - можна як за комп’ютером, так і,
перепрошую, в'язати спицями носочки.
Однак такі простори і садочки - приватні ініціативи
й радше винятки. Аби масово залучити жінок
із дітьми до роботи, необхідні зміни й стимули
на законодавчому рівні. В українському парламенті
беруть до уваги досвід інших країн. Наприклад,
у Франції дітям гарантують місце в садочку
ще з тримісячного віку, а в Швеції батько дитини
зобов’язаний піти в декретну відпустку на 90 днів.
- Четверо моїх колег від початку скликання
стали татами і жоден із них не взяв якоїсь відпустки
по догляду за дитиною. Я думаю, що
декретні відпустки в нашій країні для чоловіків
повинні стати обов’язковими.
Звісно, наявність дітей, які потребують догляду, -
не єдина причина, чому так багато жінок
не працюють. Майже третина з них готові
вийти на роботу, але бояться, що не знайдуть
потрібної вакансії чи не матимуть потім часу
на ведення домашнього господарства.
Особливо це стосується тих, кому за 40.
В Україні роботодавцям заборонено встановлювати
вікові чи статеві обмеження під час пошуку
працівників, однак оголошення рясніють ними.
Це пов'язано, зокрема, і з певними стереотипами
про жінок в українському суспільстві.
- Те, що в Україні є особливий контекст, - так, це теж правда
і це вплив попередніх режимів, у яких ми існували
дуже багато років, - це теж так.
Суспільство найчастіше бачило роль жінки
винятково як матері, як дружини і чомусь не бачить
у жінках велетенський економічний потенціал.
Використати такий потужний потенціал -
в інтересах держави. Саме український уряд
та парламент можуть створити необхідні
передумови, аби амбітні плани стали реальністю,
а українські жінки отримали  комфортні умови
для успішного працевлаштування.